joe are you from l.a
i am not i'm originally from
poughkeepsie new yorkish area
and then i lived in boston for 13 years
and then
got a call from a production company out
here who
saw a newspaper review of a show i did
in boston and that sort of got the ball
rolling to
come out and hey let's make money out
here as opposed to
really never making money in boston ever
like breaking even was the goal
for those shows may i ask what year this
was
i'm sorry may i ask questions oh yeah uh
we moved here in 97 97 okay
twenty two years ish era yes exactly
exactly okay yeah and i was on
i was online really early i did the
cleveland performance art fest i was a
performance artist and a visual artist
for
before i started doing all this stuff
and a photographer before that
so long i have a weird resume i did the
cleveland performance art festival in
and the way they described me was i was
an internet surfer
i was like joe wilson performance artist
internet surfer
and just like now we're all
internet surfers now that is not like at
that point that literally was
such a different thing to do that people
would note it and had a word
for it because it was not the norm and
really not until the phones came in and
normalized
everybody had a computer they just
called it a phone and that changed
behavior and and i think that changed
behavior to
you know david lynch hates that people
watch movies on their phone but a lot of
people watch movies on their phone
and now they're making them on their
phones too so i
i think it's a good thing
what did you love about los angeles when
you first moved here
uh potential
i guess it was i
i came here and was head down and had a
five-year plan and if things weren't
working in five years i was pulling out
and i literally got married moved here
two weeks afterwards
and i was
writing i was doing stand-up i was
acting
i was taking acting classes and improv
classes and writing classes and
at some point i felt really spread thin
and i stopped doing stand-up for a while
and really focused on screenwriting
because i kind of felt like that was
probably what i was going to end up
doing it seemed like the thing that fit
well because acting
acting is a lot of fun but acting and
crappy stuff is not
and auditioning for crappy stuff is even
less fun
and uh so when things stop being fun
and you're not making any money doing
them
then you start to question why you're
doing them
and so i really honed in on writing for
a while and then i started doing
stand-up again
i never really went back to acting i may
have done a couple of things because
people have asked me to do stuff
but i don't consider myself an actor i
do have the ability to pretend
professionally i've been paid so sag
after has one of those things on file
for me
but i don't you know i did a pilot in a
couple of commercials and i think what i
did was
uh in retrospect i'm on my fifth to
fifth five year plan and
uh and they've never worked
they've never worked all five year plans
are
i mean it's a nice to look at a chunk of
time and say you know this is going to
be done by this
but bird's eye view
now that i've seen like 22 years click
buy
the open mic that i went to when i first
moved here
those are the relationships that turned
into business literally like 15
20 years later uh because of
relationships that happened
there and i think when you're
when you're all low on the totem pole
you consider
everyone else low on the totem pole
because you're low on the totem pole
and you don't realize oh wow this is you
know
it's hard to figure out who to
collaborate with because you're trying
to find the right personality
but uh that is where
you know i know people for all that time
and i know that's when
that's when the connections were made
and that's when
you know you want to work with people
you like people you know and
so if you know people and they get a gig
they tend to bring in people that they
know
which is nice i've had it happen a
couple of times
well from having interviewed you in 2012
and 2013
i am not going to call you the c word
which i had called you before
and that is content creator yeah sorry
yeah
yeah not the other day yeah yeah that'll
call you off the air so
you're kidding okay but um so with the
five year plan the first one
what was then the backup if that didn't
work uh
there wasn't a backup you just knew that
the initial five-year period
well i just looked at it as if if i
didn't see any indication that i wasn't
out of my mind
trying to do this stuff then um
i would keep going and there was always
enough i got a pilot in two years
um so thing you know i got a comedy
central national um stand-up contest
in like the third year i was here so
stuff
stuff really happened really quick uh
and then stuff
didn't happen for a long time and then
stuff happened again and uh
i listened to a lot of bad advice
um i think i spent
i sort of looked at the entertainment
industry like well if i'm a good student
and of the industry and i you know read
all the trades and
know all the stuff that's going on and
and
[Music]
that that somehow would make me
better as a property as a
an entity to sell as a writer and
it was a complete waste of time just
just because i know how to you know what
ankling means doesn't mean that reading
variety is
a good use of time um especially at this
point in history
you know back then it was it was you
know came out
five days a week it was thick it was
there was a ton of information in it now
it's like once a week and it's like a
pamphlet
and it doesn't matter you know a lot of
things
matter less now because there is
so much to watch
there has never been this much to watch
and there will never be less than right
now
who was the bad advice from bad advice
was from
other comedians other actors other
people
in improv classes
teachers
[Music]
mentors losing a word loosely
i think what it is that you tell
yourself how it's going to be
and so when things start to happen like
like you've heard other people's careers
happen like
uh i was i was in the uh uh write it
respect screenplay uh get in a contest
get a manager
sell it that was it that was the whole
plan
and uh so i did that a couple times
and had people tell me i was gonna be a
millionaire and very nice to have people
tell you who
have made other people millionaires that
you're going to be a millionaire it's
very nice
especially when you're writing stuff
that is to sell
it was written to sell high concept
comedies the
elevator pitch that you only need half
the elevator ride to pitch it like
it's that kind of quick stuff and that's
what i was focusing on
and i
i wasn't i guess i wasn't acclimated to
the rough ride that was coming
i didn't realize how much people would
lie to me
uh people who represented me people who
i worked with people i collaborated with
uh
just wow
there's definitely that element here
which is i think a surprise to a lot of
people that
aren't from here you know it doesn't
surprise me i just
i exp my expectation is that
when someone represents themselves as
something especially because
you know when you first move here you're
so impressed with people's resumes you
know if they've done anything
they know more than you and the problem
is is that maybe they just got lucky
and they're full of and they don't
know anything they're just blah blah
blah blah
and they happen to teach a workshop that
you can pay for
and and then you realize oh so that
resume thing that they have
that was really the only thing that
they've ever had and they've been
cashing in on that thing
doing these workshops acting improv
writing screenwriting
whatever and i understand people want to
make money and people have information
but that there is a dark side to that
uh and it
you know at some point i
hit i hit the wall i was just so sick
of me working my ass off
to hear now again you know at some point
you're like all right so
i'm gonna work my day job all day which
i was a private investigator working at
home so i had one desk
and i'm working all day and then day's
over and then i go over to another desk
and i'll bring a screenplay
and then i go back to work and so do
that for
i don't know years
and at some point you start to think wow
so this is my life right now and it's
going right by and all i'm doing is
typing here here's another one
no okay this is great
oh this is the best i'm writing stories
that are going to make people
laugh and oh no i'm not i'm just filling
up hard drives with a bunch of
bites
no one's ever going to see the
screenplays they will die
like most screenplays that's what
happens and i think the
the thing that i am glad i came to the
conclusion
was i didn't
i just wanted to make something
i was so sick of just like why does
someone have to give me permission
and the thing that that uh uh anger is
an energy
uh it's a public uh image limited song
and it made me angry
that i i wrote three short screenplays
and
all of them were shot by people who two
of them had gone to film like good film
schools
and they were um garbage they were
garbage and i was just like
i just wrote three shorts for you people
to make and oh my god this stuff is
garbage i'm gonna have to learn how to
direct now great
i didn't want to direct i just knew the
only way that i'm going to have
any ability to get the tone of this
comedy
where it needs to be is for me to be in
the room
controlling that tone because
they don't get it on the paper they hear
they hear your head you're handing them
heavy metal and they're giving you back
poca
and you're like you know i just gave you
i worked my ass off for you
for this heavy metal and you're handing
me back this doo-da-doo crap
and it sounds like and that
dialogue is music
comedy is music it's you know drama
comedy that dialogue there is it just it
has a timing it has a
uh an effect it's
it's and when someone else it up
and then
i had to learn to edit and i had to
learn to shoot and i'd learn to mix
sound i
learned to do little special effects and
i learned to work with fight
choreographers and produce
and all the post-production because if i
knew how to do all
i wouldn't have to count on anybody so i
got it down to all i need is actors
i can do literally every other job i
have shot there's a short i made called
clyde hates bonnie
that i shot solo i'm the only camera
person
i'm the director i'm the camera person
we worked with a choreographer we
had two rehearsals two two fight
rehearsals
and uh only time i ever storyboarded
and i uh
and it worked like i was amazed like i
always think
we got to have you know you can have
people and
all the people and now you don't need
all the people
you don't need all the people really
break it down what do you need well i
need a camera and sound and light and an
actor right there's nothing else i need
it's pretty simple
that and some place to shoot once you
have all that then you can shoot
anything
do you really think people were lying to
you in the beginning or
were they saying these things that were
sort of the catchphrase at the moment
oh the gatekeepers and you you know and
and that was like trendy back in like
2013 and then there's a new way to do it
and then a new way oh yeah
there's always a new way and there's
always a new story and that never ends
i know for a fact that i was lied to
on a number of occasions by
individuals and it
sometimes it was milds the information
and sometimes it was
information that if i had uh would have
been uh less catastrophic
why did they lie to you uh they were
afraid of the truth
and they were the one that had to
deliver it and
they didn't have the guts so
i had to find out through other means
and uh
and that was after years of
collaboration
you know how they say in storytelling
there's like these tricksters
shape-shifters whatever do you think
some of them were those
or no i think they're just okay
it's it's the brand
the type of the
the level of entitlement that happens in
los angeles is a different brand of
entitlement that happens in anywhere
else other than maybe you know parts of
new york city
parts of paris part to london but la's
got a big
mass of just people who have arrived
here
waiting for someone to know who they are
and i've i've been in
super successful realms and i've been in
super not successful realms with people
and
like i worked with michael j fox and a
sitcom and tracy pollen
they were the nicest human beings i was
i was kind of like
you're so nice like i'm i've got like
nothing i'm a nothing part i got two
scenes and i'd do nothing in those
scenes
and he came up to me he was like hi i'm
mike fox and i was just like no you're
michael j
fox and you just said your name wrong
and
and then a week after we shot the oddly
we shot the pilot in november he
announced he had parkinson's
and you could not see it you did not
know it and the idea was that he was
going to produce it and she was going to
be on camera
and he was going to be slowly moving
away from them and
it didn't get picked up telling stories
has been fun for you
working in the entertainment industry
not so fun
i think that was a quote from you
somewhere yeah i think
[Music]
at some point when you're banging your
head against the wall and you're trying
and that and that is
i mean that is a career that is what you
do if you want to be successful you keep
writing and you keep banging your head
against that wall until something goes
the thing that crossed my mind
because i had some friends die young was
that i was
relatively young and
was i going to die typing and
not making anything like all i want like
i made
i wrote to have three shorts made
because i just wanted to have something
made
like just well i'm typing i just want to
see
this happen and then when i saw it
happen like i literally could not go to
the screening because i was so angry
at how bad everything was and and
so i i
think at some point i was just like
literally like
this why am i doing this what this
has been
years and i have gone through
managers and ups and downs and
projects that were going to be huge and
and
not you know little tiny things happen
but not enough for a career
not enough to you know you you all
you're doing
is stringing together a bunch of temp
jobs that is what the
entertainment industry is it is a bunch
of temp jobs yeah maybe you get lucky
enough to be on a show that lasts for
years
but most of the time these are temp jobs
you're working one day maybe a week
maybe a few months
and then there's no work and sometimes
you have a great gig
and you make a ton of money and then
nothing happens
ever again and that is a reality
that happens no one wants to talk about
it because
no one wants to hear you know there's
this really good possibility
you're going to spend all your time and
all your life and all this time
nothing's going to happen and you're and
that's it
and you're going to look back and you're
going to think hey that was a lot of
money that was a lot of time
wow so that was my life huh interesting
maybe maybe i want to change things up a
little bit and
the most fun i had was when i said
it the most fun i had
that's when things started going
together that's when things started just
it seemed effortless when i stopped
looking for people
to say yes to a script when i was just
like i'm making this do you want to help
changes everything and then when you
make something
and it doesn't suck and then you can use
that to make something else and then
that doesn't suck
and then you use that and you can then
you're slowly building these little tiny
increments until you have a couple hours
online
of a bunch of stuff you've made and then
it exists and people see it and it
doesn't disappear
and what's amazing and the thing that
you do not know when
you make anything online is stuff that i
made
in 06 i got a comment on last week
oh wow so that's the thing that nobody
tells you like
this youtube's not going anywhere it's
not going and there and as far as i know
they're not cleaning out the old stuff
so if you have your short up there
yeah maybe it doesn't have 20 billion
views maybe it didn't go viral maybe
whatever
maybe just maybe it doesn't suck maybe
it will
entertain amuse whatever someone
why did you start to do this to begin
with and i started to do this because i
was like i love when i'm sitting down
and something happens on a screen or on
a stage and i and it makes me feel
different i want to be able to create
that
how do i do that spend decades
typing and stand up and acting and like
going to school for photography really
came in handy when i was a director
because all of a sudden
all of a sudden the the slr was a video
camera
and i'm like yeah i know that all these
numbers have had to memorize forever
like i can i can tell everybody what
f-stop to go to because i knew it when i
was 11.
like so it made all this stuff really
easy
you know i knew focal lengths and all
that stuff
none of it i knew the shape of 35
millimeter because i had been taking
pictures and trying to fit the world in
that so i had
i was one up on everybody i didn't need
a director of photography because they'd
taken so many great pictures because
i spent years learning how to do it so
now i'm just
making ones that move that's why i never
went tripod
because i'm like i want to be able to
get whatever i want whenever i want it i
do not want to try pot around it's too
slow it's too slow i want three cameras
two operators here i'm operating boom
cover cover cover cover cover next
did your parents like their jobs you
know yeah
my father i think i did for to some
degree and i think
my mother tolerated it i guess
they both came from poor backgrounds and
my father was a
construction worked in construction as a
plumber union uh down austin
area and my mother worked on an assembly
line for ibm
and then worked her way up to be a cat
operator and then
[Music]
both of them got screwed over they
forced everybody into retirement
and then hired people back as temps to
to train their replacements oh wonderful
and then the the union was starting to
run out of money
and started cutting off you know
uh benefits and stuff so i think when i
saw them get screwed i was just like
i'm not gonna work my ass off so
so i can be a cog in somebody else's
machine
just that is the one great thing that
came from
my parents going like they did all the
right things
american dream high school educated
family we all went to college house
they did everything right still got
screwed
so i didn't want to do that
so do you think that's what kind of like
lit a fire under you
to say okay i'm gonna go from wherever
to boston
do some stuff okay then i'm gonna take
this chance this person
communicated with me said come to la and
so you knew that that's not the life for
joe wilson
i i'm not going to be doing that i'm not
going to work for some company
and then being politely or not so
politely pushed out the door
yeah that was the goal i did end up
working for a company for 11 years
that i own a little tiny piece of that
was started by writers and actors
that's still in business um so
it's not like i'm against you know i'm
not like damn the corporations i just
know what happens to companies when they
get big
when companies get big they care less
about people
they you know when ford had the pinto in
the 70s and when people hit it and it
blew up
ford said well we can either recall and
pay for that or we can just pay for all
the lawsuits
and they chose the lawsuits and they're
still in business
amazing i have one of their cars so
do you ever go back and say well i know
i'm typing at this one desk and here i'm
wearing this one
metaphorical hat as this job and then
i'm turning around and i'm typing at
this other desk as a quote
creative storyteller even if i don't
make a million dollars right away or in
the next 20 years
i still got to do this or ever i still
want to do this because this is who i am
and i can't stop telling stories and i
don't want to
have a job that i hate that i have to go
to and i have to smile at people and
make it seem like i want to be there and
i don't really want to be there
and my boss is an idiot and i'm having
meetings about meetings
but i didn't do this screenwriting so
i've given up
i think there's a question
sorry i
um i don't know say that well i guess my
question with all that
gibbering jabbering that i'm doing is
like even if
there isn't hollywood putting a stamp
even though
people love vampire mob and it has views
and people gave you feedback
yeah sure if you want to do a second
version of something
right but no because hollywood said they
didn't want me
so put it right i'm not touching that
again
is that where you're at i guess i got
there
years ago to
not acknowledge the entertainment
industry to kind of like
if i if i could make something without
it
then and the end result
it was it was sort of like i needed to
get to the audience
and the thing that was between me and
the audience was all the companies that
make the to show to the audience so
if i could find some way to get around
them
and get to the audience which social
media
allowed um you know and i've
i've had people and continue to have
people find stuff
and and like stuff and you know
you make somebody laugh when they're
having a bad day or a bad life or a bad
you know time and i know
[Music]
my wife was diagnosed with cancer a few
years ago and
i know how much comedy really can help
like i have seen it firsthand so there's
a value
in in making stories you know whether
it's drama or comedy or whatever the
genre but
i think you know now because there's i
think
the number of
guest star performances to be considered
for emmys was 2
800 and something performances
so if you have that many potential
nominees
for for guests
when you have thousands of performances
and you have thousands
you literally there are more shows
than anyone can get to in their lifetime
if they wanted to do it full-time
and just watched television they
couldn't get to it all
so now i'm making
more stuff for them to watch
why why am i going to make something
that i have to be in the same boat that
netflix and
everyone else is like how do you get all
these how do you get that much attention
like everyone is so twitter facebook
instagram snapchat what i gotta watch
something what
oh there's something right yeah music
how do you get their attention
they i think if you're going to be
indie that you have to spend years
getting to know your audience and
talking to
and i and i have changed my term a
little bit in terms of audience
because now i
i see the people i know online as
neighbors
because i talk to them all the time
you don't talk to audience all the time
audience is this
thing that's over there and you're over
here and
and i think a lot of people like that
a lot of people like hey i'm over here
you're over there
i act you stay over there i'm a director
you stay over there when you talk to
people every day
because you're not making everything all
the time like you
i don't care how good of a producer or
you're not putting out movies all the
time as an
indie person so there's going to be all
this time that you're not going to have
something new
and if you're spending all your time on
social media talking about your
project
jesus christ really more tell us
more you typed another page yay come on
that is not i i know what interests you
and i know it's a great thing for you
but you're just
typing you know you finished a
screenplay okay i'll give you that
but i i did another thousand words shut
up
tell me about the thousand words after
you've done fifty thousand and then a
hundred thousand and then
three hundred thousand then maybe you
talk about the words a little bit but
just because you typed all november to
get to get a novel out doesn't mean you
made anything good it just means you
typed every day
uh i don't know what that tangent was
about that's okay
i enjoyed it oh good i'm glad know there
was a point to this
therapeutics the i think the
a story can have a value without the
entertainment industry
and the entertainment industry doesn't
value stories they value
profit uh the marvel universe
is a very big complicated story but that
is something that has an audience that
was built in
for decades and you only market at a
level
that is saturation when you're playing
with
literally billions of dollars but all
that's for
other people that's not for me that's
not for most
people that is that's the giant machine
that is
you will be a cog in that machine unless
you're on screen
you will be because it's just too big
and even if you
are on screen you're still really
disposable because that
is disney has bought the world and that
is
really valuable property right now
just like in um say anything and forgive
me i'm
bringing on uh john cusack's character
but he's basically i don't want to you
know produce
oh yeah you know buy anything that you
know
i was talking her dad at dinner right
right right aren't we all
sort of owned by somebody though
i don't care if we work for marvel and
oh yeah yeah and we're
and they want your picture or sure
you're working for a company yeah you
got to work you have to work for
somebody yeah we all like to own
an online reselling business to sell
stuff to make money that way
so all of my customers are technically
my balls
sure sure uh i don't think nor do i
expect what i make to generate enough
income for me to live
on what i do online it's more it's just
like anything
else it's a gig it's just a little gig
you do something
maybe make a tiny little bit of money
and then gotta put another one together
and another one together and
uh i was on a roll
when my wife had cancer that roll the
wind and the sails
stopped and storytelling was not
important anymore
and was not a priority
and was not anything that i thought
about
for a long time because i had other
stuff that was more important and i
think
i think the other thing about this is
that sometimes and i've seen people do
it
to their demise literally
sometimes people make the entertainment
industry and success in it more
important than anything else including
other people
and at some point you're going to
end up being an empty shell of a human
being at the other end of it
and you will
maybe you won't regret it but man you're
going to be bitter as hell
because it's just
when when when the
the socializing in los angeles is based
on perceived
success whether it's current recent or
about to happen and people i've had the
and it's the classic thing you're at the
party and someone's talking to you but
they're like
and that person's way more important i
really need to go talk to that person
but
yeah yeah yeah i'll be here with you and
then they go talk to that person or or
the classic hey you're going to come to
my show
now when is that uh no is it already if
i show up late
oh no you know i think i have this thing
you know i'll try to be there
okay that's in la that's an la
definitely
you're definitely going to be there then
i'm definitely probably trying to
maybe be there yeah maybe but i'll but
i'll try
thank you they're not showing up i
remember when i was doing stand-up
comedy everybody was doing one-man shows
or one for solo shows
so everybody was just trading off
everybody's just going to each other's
shows
because we needed an audience and
because there's just so many comedians
and there was so little audience in los
angeles
well it's gotten that way with
crowdfunding it's like you want to
donate to people's campaigns but after a
while
we just had another guest that reminded
me of that and that's a great point
that you want to be able to give to
these campaigns over and over again
but you've already given to so many and
you're kind of like tapped out
and i think that's that's part of the
problem but
going back to storytelling do you plan
on giving up storytelling
no no no no no i
when i was doing vampire mob
i uh one of the cast members marshall
wallace died
and i had written a whole season three
and uh the idea of trying to make it
without her seems
weird like i easily could have written
her out i easily could have cast someone
else
and it was just kind of like this
isn't i don't know it just didn't feel
right so i went graphic novel
i went comic book and i don't know
anything about comic books i didn't grow
up reading comic books i'm not a comic
book guy so then i had to
learn about comic books learn how to
write comic books
and man i wish i had done that like
before i ever took a screenwriting class
because
for you to have so i'm adapting a
screenplay
into a comic book so i have it all
written
but it can't just get dropped
it isn't like i'm just taking the script
and then oh look it's a storyboard with
words
it's like you have to go through and
like what are the
five panels that you're going to put on
this page that are going to tell the
story
and you're going to have to leave most
of it out because you can't have this
giant long thing because you want to
watch your character walk through the
alley for an hour
you've gotta go so
it changes how you see story achieve now
all of a sudden you think
oh i want this panel on this page to end
so when they turn the page and they see
that top panel the surprise will be
there you're literally
writing like that there's no plot points
it's page points
and the challenges with making a graphic
novel i just put an issue too to the
printer
so the second issue will be coming out
soonish
the challenge is working with artists
getting artists
i can't draw the frustration to be
honest
putting the two books together has
resulted in me writing a book
so i am 45 000 words into
something called bob berry's things it
was an idea i had a couple of years ago
and
i just needed something somewhere to go
like i when i'm writing i'm i disappear
completely that's
the way i look at it i'm daydreaming on
a page
writing is orchestrated daydreaming i'm
just
daydreaming it's not hard to daydream
so it's really easy and i like it and
now i've
spent it takes a long time to write a
book and i expect like 50 people to read
it
and that's my expectation and maybe my
expectation will be beat but i'm asking
somebody to not only take
time out of their day but a lot of time
to read a book
so i don't have
any expectation i don't know what people
will
i didn't write this from a marketing
point a genre point anything like that
it was just an idea and i ran with it
and
and the weirdest thing is i i listen to
the book i have the program read it back
to me
so it's sort of like an audiobook being
read by a robot and i listen to what i
wrote
and then i hear what's wrong with it and
then i can go back
and change it that i never would see if
i was just
just reading and even if i was reading
it loud
i wouldn't catch it like that
can you tell us more about this book
that you're writing joe yeah it
i had an idea about a guy who was
burying things in his backyard
and i had an idea of what he was burying
and that was all i knew so i had to
write a story
around around the idea and
uh i've never written a book before
i have never
written what a character has thought
ever
because you can't write what characters
think in screenplays
because they have to say it or it's got
to be a voiceover and i've always been
of the anti-voiceover school although i
know it comes in handy
it's really lazy screenwriting sorry
um but to
being able to get in the head of a
character and and be able to like
essentially be in the middle of what is
what would be a scene
and then jumping into this giant sort of
exposition flashback
thing and then go right back into the
scene afterwards that's really hard to
do on screen
uh like that you can't hear what other
you know
what one character's thinking these
little tiny things that you can throw
out and also it's just fun to play with
words and
and try to find you know
i go through and i'll i'll catch myself
saying a phrase more than once
because i'm only one person and i only
have so many phrases
but i'm going through and i'm like yeah
i said that i've already said that i
can't use that little
linguistic thing again
um so it's
it's a lot more solitary uh
than screenwriting because i think it
takes longer
depending on the screenplay but i think
writing book takes longer and it's also
harder to
you know it's always hard to get
somebody to read your screenplay and
give you feedback it's really
worse for a book i planned on paying an
editor a friend of mine who
worked as a journalist went to school
for journalism had offered to
has offered to edit it so he's editing
it so i'm lucky
in that regard um because he's really a
stickler for
all the grammar and all the things and
all the
uh and he goes every through everything
four times
until he finds it but um and i the
graphic novel
i'll put out uh next month i guess at
the rate it's going and then
i'll put the book out next year 2020
i'm guessing unless something
i'll put the book out in 2020 unless uh
something changes and
things always change
how do you plan to write a story you
make a big mess and then try to pluck
the good stuff
out uh i sit down with a legal pad and
i write down
little tiny bios uh lines
um basic stories conflicts
secrets all that kind of stuff and i
don't like like it's not neat
like there's circles and lines and
scribbles and stuff text out and
and i only use one side so i just keep
going and then i will go back through
and
okay that's kind of interesting that's
sort of good that's kind of interesting
all the stuff i'll get to and i no lie
have
stacks of yellow legal pads
that are from projects and like with the
vampire mob
i had to
[Music]
i had to i never plan on writing how the
main character became a vampire
because i wanted it it was the
screenwriting thing of starting as late
in the scene as you can so i wanted to
start after he was a vampire when his
mother-in-law moved in for eternity i
thought that was more fun
so in the vampire mob issue 2
i have a little 10-page mini comic that
is the
origin story of the main character so
this is him before he was a vampire and
why he became a vampire
and it was something i never shot before
and
so i'm writing the comic book and i go
back to the
legal pads from 2009 2010 and i'm going
through and i'm like
oh yeah that thing that's
where i'm going to go and a boom just
found a way to do it and it was
literally a line
that ended up in season one
uh that was something about doing the
whole light at the end of the tunnel
thing
and i'm like what's in the tunnel what's
in the tunnel
and that was enough to just go so i
think when you're building a story it's
you're you know your character has to
want something out of obstacles and all
that stuff but i also think like
you have to have fun
making the character do stuff like it's
the old get your character in a tree and
throw rocks at them
um like this should be fun for the
audience this should be fun
for you this should be fun like if it's
drudgery
like i never felt like a drudgery when i
was writing except for one screenplay
because it wasn't my idea and
sorry to interrupt interject but you
said secrets
from your time as a private investigator
did you start to realize how important
secrets are
to what makes up a character
what drives people i guess
when i worked as a private investigator
i had to call people
pretending to be someone who didn't
exist
using a name that wasn't mine calling
from a company
that wasn't real with a story that was
completely made up
so i could get information social
engineering
social engineering so that is
a hard thing to teach someone how to do
and i almost think it's kind of him like
you have to learn in the trenches
um so i i guess what i learned being a
private investigator was
it's like being a con man
it's a confidence game so
i could change my voice change how fast
i talk
change my tone
i would always say my name the company
where i was calling from
because if you give all the information
out front then they're like okay
and then you start giving them
the and then you start throwing
them what i call misdirects
which are questions that you do not need
the answers to
because you have to stack up the
conversation to be thick enough
to not have those questions light up
like why is he asking me this because
it's like oh all these other questions
and oh this thing just dropped
you drop it in and you kind of ride the
conversation like a wave
and you just drop stuff in and sometimes
you're like i gotta force this wave and
sometimes it works and sometimes it
doesn't
but i
am a really good liar i guess and
i and it was storytelling i was telling
people stories i was
making up you know i had my lines down
and sometimes you know
people would come back come at me and i
would have to come up with another story
on the spot and be able to cover it
so i was i was investigating a guy who
was in court with the client
so i we used to call these cases uh the
crazy
because this is a crash and burn you go
in you either get the information
or you don't this guy's in court he he's
gonna know
most likely that you are calling from
the other side
because he's in court so i call from the
other side got a great thing
and this guy starts slamming me he's
like what's what's the phone number i
give him the phone what's the main
number for your company i don't know the
main number
how do you work at a company not know
the main number uh sir temp i walked in
there this morning they put me down in a
cubicle i'm sitting down i have this
phone number right here so what i need
to do is get off the phone with you
get on the phone with my manager ask him
what that phone number is and then i
will call you back with that number
is that all right sir yes so i hang up i
call another investigator here's the
deal the name of the company is this
you're my boss this is what we do
click call the guy back okay sir here's
the number oh you know
i'm just in the middle of this whole
thing with lawyers and i just thought
you're one of them what did you need to
know
blah blah blah gives me everything i
need to know
because the suspension of disbelief
is a real thing it happens in the real
world
so they suspend their disbelief that i'm
not who i
say i am and they give me information
that why in god's name would i be asking
that
so the story so you have to know who
they are to figure out who you are
because you've got to figure out some
something that is either not symbiotic
at all
or potentially symbiotic because you
need
some some reason it's either
i need something from you maybe you need
something for me
we're going to help each other out it's
[Music]
social engineering
having been on um i don't want to say
that side but having been
aware of of some of that and now we're
in this new age of
people's secrets coming out and it's
instant on
on social media do you feel that that's
an integral part
to doing a backstory on a character
yeah i think the when i was working as a
pi
i knew people would google and i knew
that we needed to keep track of all the
pretext to make sure nothing got burnt
so if a pretext gets burnt it means they
somebody has figured out exactly what
happened they know exactly who did it
they knew they were lied to they know
they know the whole deal and they go
online with it
then that's burnt you can't use that
anymore
that story's garbage now because
somebody else is going to google it and
they're going to find it
so now you got to change up your names
you got to change up your
your story now what was the question
so just secrets being an important part
of a character's backstory and a
character's motives and a character's
arc
yeah i think there are things about
uh like characters in vampire mob even
the characters in
play shorts the other series i made that
i know about them that nobody else knows
and no one else will know like i know
there's a big
overarching thing with vampire mob and i
know what it's about and no one else
does
and i know what the end is and
i don't know if anyone else will ever
know or need to know but
i wrote i wrote an
hour and 15 minute third season
screen time so i'm translating that into
comic books
so i have i have a lot of stuff written
that's already done so i have all these
secrets that i'm getting to sort of drag
into more stories and some that we
haven't that we will learn actually
so you think that's okay to do with
characters to how the writer has their
secrets
in the back pocket they have their own
file on them so to speak
but the audience isn't privy to that
that works
yeah i think i think the audience the
writer needs to know more about
the character than the audience will
ever know or could know
because you're not going to have the
time to explain all this about them
so if you have you know uh i can't
remember it was a psychology thing of
like
where you are when you're 16 is pretty
close to who you are
most of the developments happen not that
there's going you know more education
changes maturity all the rest of that
but the baseline is about there at 16.
so if you take your character to 16
if everything's there what happened to
put it there
so it's literally just going back and
okay well if they're if they're doing
this
and they're in this kind of job or in
this kind of situation
then they most likely came from this
kind of background
that would bring them into this world
how
and then you sort of reverse engineer it
and then go back
because sometimes i think my mistake was
not knowing enough about characters when
i started writing stuff i knew
like i thought i knew bare bones about
the character and i needed to know way
more
and i and i don't mean you have to like
write an entire bio
but you need to know a bunch of stuff
about these people because
when you're writing about them and
they're saying something
and the other character says something
and their response
is specific
because of who they are specifically
because the secret you know
it's fuels that response if you don't
know that and maybe it will come out in
the screenplay or
whatever the presentation you're using
but
it's it's the work that actors do
when if i give an actor a screenplay
they have
a script and they have the words the
saying they sort of know the situation
maybe they ask a couple of questions but
then it's going back to
they have to create that character what
kind of shoes do they wear where you
know where did they grow up what kind of
school did they go to you have to
all the stuff that's not going to be on
screen because it will show up on screen
both in writing and in acting there's
something about the grounding of a
character knowing
you know where do they live what you
know what does the room look like that
kind of stuff
do they have books on the shelves do
they not have books on the show do they
listen to music
uh were they ever involved in a crime
all this stuff and it just builds and
builds so you have
and and you need that for everybody
your minor characters need to have some
interesting stuff going on otherwise
they're just
window dressing and they're not that you
know especially when you have minor
characters who
are so interesting they're almost more
interesting than the main character and
you're
and they're only there for a little bit
of time to make that happen you need to
know a lot about that character the
character's got to have
something going on maybe they have the
secrets that the the person's looking
for
um i just
if you're not writing something
and it's fun if it's not fun you're
writing it it's not fun
why are you writing it like if it's if
okay i'm writing this
i don't enjoy this at all i'm hoping it
sells
when it sells then maybe i'll start like
liking writing like
that's a horrible plan that is you
better like writing
because you're going to be doing a lot
of it and a lot of it is not going to be
seen a lot of it's going to get rejected
you are and also
you're going to write i know i've
written some shitty stuff my first book
will hopefully be better because of all
the other stuff i've written but it's
still not going to be the best book i've
ever written because it's my first book
but i i i know their screenplay
structure in it i know like i can
feel like i can feel the first act i can
feel this is kind of what puts this into
place here's the sort of midpoint here's
the big second act plot point
now we're just putting everything down
and and it's so great writing without a
budget
i don't have to shoot this i don't have
to find this location i don't have to
figure out somebody who knows how to use
drones
like you know it's so much easier when
you're just like
oh you know what a house it can be
whatever kind of house i want
because i'm not gonna find it
because i'm not gonna shoot it
yay
that's a nice freedom to have but also
when the audience experiences that story
when you're reading a book you're
in their head in a different place than
when they're watching it on screen
um most likely they're not going to jump
you know when they're reading the book
oh you know that's probably not going to
happen they'll do that more on screen
they might go oh my god but it's not
going to be that
that visceral you know when you see an
entire movie theater
jump at the same time that's not going
to happen if they're all reading a book
what do you think the audience wants
from a character
i think it's different for
every audience um
because we are at an interesting point
in history
um and the world seems a little extra
dark
um maybe we don't need more dark stories
or maybe we do uh i think there's
something
you know i people go to scary movies to
be scared because there's not enough
real scary stuff in their life
now there's a bunch of real scary stuff
so i'm wondering if they still need that
scary thing especially we need to go to
movie theater to be scared
which is scary just to go to the movie
theater at this point in history
um i think
they i think people need characters who
are inspiring but
not in a uh
quote way not in a self-help way not in
a hero
but you know some small cat like i love
um characters who are in episodics who
you get to see go through a bunch of
stuff
and because it's such a long movie it's
an 18-hour movie
so you get to see them go through all
these different things that you wouldn't
if it was in a much shorter amount of
time
and then and because now you're fed the
whole
here's here's the 18 hours here's this
whole season go watch it
and then you watch it and they're like
so how much longer for the next one
three years what the hell
but you'll wait cause you binged you
were
into it you were there was nothing else
it was just you and those characters and
on that trip and
and uh and it was fun and now you want
to see what happens to them
in the future i think that's uh
i think yeah
comedy is going to be more important
than it ever has been
um and it shouldn't be looked on as
being frivolous
just because dramas are seen as more
important
comedies uh help more than dramas do uh
i think because we need way more
laughing now
than we did before and not the drama
doesn't have a you know you want to get
lost in their world and cry your brains
out great but
i think a lot more people are going to
be looking for comedy
so we want something in a character that
we can kind of like latch onto
whether we see ourselves in that
character whether that character is
classically good or bad
right and do you think that's why big
little lies was such a
there was such an appeal because at
first you just kind of saw them is
these women that you know oh you never
saw the show
okay all right but i i guess what has
what i've always wondered was why do
people have an interest in spending time
with a hitman like i wrote a story about
a guy who kills people professionally
that's his job and
people like him like his character is
likeable at some degree
the sopranos yeah it's i mean yeah it's
always
godfather all of the mafia stuff that's
always been there but it's
but when you break it down when you
actually like go bird's-eye view like
why am i so interested in this
guy who runs a crime family who has
anxiety attacks like
yeah and why and why am i going to watch
it when it's on on sunday night at the
right time
like that that is um
that's never you know that'll never go
away martin scorsese's got another one
on deck and it's
you know i think the crime stuff is
never going to go away procedural or
procedurals have never gone away and it
seems like there's even more now
people love the crime stuff
why is storytelling important to you i
guess i feel like
some degree it's um a service
um not like a like a
car repair service but you're
you are in service to storytelling
whether it's
you know nobody starts and makes money
so or few people do so
if you're telling stories then it's
because
you want to like you would
you're spending time with these
characters and building this world
without most of the time without anyone
watching without
anyone seeing and so you're
alone with it but you're making it to
give
to other people so it's a
service you are at the service of
the reader the audience the whoever is
experiencing whatever you're making
and whatever medium or media as the case
would be
[Music]
so i guess it's important to me because
i feel like i'm
[Music]
helping a little bit um
for what what do you have stories gives
people somewhere to go away from all
this
from to suspend their disbelief to go
hang out with a
hitman who's a vampire and drive around
and kill some people
that is an escape for people it is
somewhere to go it is suspension of
disbelief stories have been around since
the beginning of time because that's
what we all
sat around and did because it was really
shitty wi-fi when you were a caveman
and so people were telling stories and
drawing stuff
and and then it's you know then it's
just verbal then it's just
one generation telling the next
generation telling the next generation
until you start writing that stuff down
so i and and stories are
man you can get people killed with
stories you can
change people's lives with stories you
can
a whole country can believe a story and
and do really bad things
and have been done yeah yeah
storytelling is
is really powerful that suspension of
disbelief thing
the real world uses it all the time
it's not just for storytellers
what about if a writer says storytelling
for me is a selfish
uh motive is a selfish endeavor and i
make no apologies for it
i love creating other worlds it doesn't
even mean i need people to love the
story
i just love to be yeah that
sounds fantastic but that storyteller's
the whole not needing any one thing is
then no one's
gonna see your man you're you're
just gonna type in just like
i'm just gonna fill up hard drives with
stories because i love it so much and
i'm so
great really are you just waiting until
you die and then someone's going to
publish all your stuff
and no i
i think that person's if maybe if that's
what it takes for them to be able
to write great but the reality is if no
one sees it then
you know like screenplays are maps for
movies they're not meant to be read
they're meant to be made so all the
movies that i have written so far
have not been made and will not be made
and that's okay that's uh some of them
are shitty
um a couple of them i'm
probably going to adapt into books
because they were fun
to write then and they would be i think
more fun as a book and i wouldn't have
to deal with trying to get it done
and also if i was to make a movie it
would be indie and i
know what it's like to be crushed by
production i would never make a movie at
this point
just because i can't do anything else
when i'm making a movie
i know people have made movies it's two
years
pretty much at least all the time full
time
um and
and it's really expensive and
it takes a lot of people and it takes a
lot of people
who have to stay with the project it's
really hard to keep people motivated
when they're not making a lot of money
and most likely i'm making a movie where
they're not making a lot of money
and then after i have that movie made
then i have to get people to watch it
and all of that seems like
too much to do
[Music]
for me for the amount of time i've got
left on the planet
and for what else i think i could
achieve in the same amount of time
[Music]
and also i could make a shitty movie so
i'd hate to spend two years making
do you think a storyteller is lying to
themselves
or in some type of delusion to think
that they just want to write for
themselves and they don't need an
audience
i mean you can write a blog and not show
it to anybody
you can write books and screenplays and
never show them to anybody but then
[Music]
what do the if if no one sees them then
they don't exist
you're you're just you're creating
something in a little silo that no one's
ever going to be inside of
and if i think to some degree you need
to suspend your disbelief
that you know someone's going to make
this
i can see it on screen i'm at you know i
think you need to do that
um i interviewed derek haas
and i'm blanking on the other writer
it's a writing team i interviewed them a
long time ago
for some organization on stage it was a
writer's thing and they had told they
just had a movie come out
and they were
driving around with the producer
and they were popping into theaters they
were just sticking their head in
and they were just spending like 10 15
minutes watching the audience watch the
movie
and then they would get back in the car
go to the next theater walk in
do it again and they kept doing that all
over town and i
and i thought and so when i started the
interview when i told them everything i
said
i want to start with that because i
think that's the thing that
when you're just typing it's hard to
imagine
and i always did it would be so great to
um you know have a company just
they give you a check and then they make
the story and it's good
and then people see it like and i always
imagined
that but i also imagined it
when the industry wasn't what it is now
and you know mark scorsese's on netflix
so
like i keep thinking uh
people are like you know you can make it
moving around so i'm like yeah martin
scorsese couldn't get his movie made so
he went to netflix
that's why he went to netflix he
couldn't get his movie made
martin scorsese with barbara tamiro
and joe pesci couldn't get his movie
made without pacino couldn't get his
move
so i should do what now i should make my
own movie and
maybe maybe go to netflix and maybe go
to them that's great
you know amazon studios ted hopes
running that thing they're making some
good stuff
i would definitely try to work with that
guy
um but i
don't have a movie in me anymore not
gonna happen
it would have to be
i know what it would take and i
would not put myself through it i think
that's okay
to be there because if you know how
expensive how time intensive
also you can put that movie out there
and then that's it
but also i like i also don't know what
what story
i want to invest that much in
like that much time that much money that
much
and and it's and i know from vampire mob
it's really hard to keep people attached
to a project
um and if you and if the ball gets
rolling
and let's say one of your cast member
dies and you're in the middle of the
movie
what do you do then you know what do you
do when one of your cast members has a
family member who dies and
you stop production and then you gotta
bring it all back up and then match all
the continuity
and that's a lot
i mean i know this is a film channel
film and screenwriting yeah
but there's something to be said for
having a book and having something in
your hand something tangible
sure and i think maybe we'll go back to
that a little bit i don't know maybe we
won't but i just
i miss that and i know right now i'm not
able to read
so i think that's okay if you're saying
i don't want to make a movie right now
but you still want to write you still
want to tell stories whether it's on
instagram
i mean i think that's wonderful i've got
38 short scripts
written done for placer it's ready to
roll
i guess in terms of it's not that i
don't have an
energy it's that i don't want to spend
the energy on one thing
like that's a big thing that's going to
take a lot of time
it would have to be a story that i was
on fire about
to to make and
[Music]
when vampire mob was
over in terms of it being a live series
i
started play shorts and i put my
producer hat on
and the weakness in vampire mob was all
the actors
like i needed the same actors to show up
and if somebody did not show up then i
had to write a reason why they didn't
want to show up and then
bring somebody else in and whatever else
with play shorts it was
uh it's uh episodic it's
it's um anthology it's
two actors one story one genre then it
ends
then there's another one two different
actors different story
different genre than it ends so
and they're all running like about 10
minutes-ish
and they're all really simple just two
people talking
sometimes guns get involved but most of
the time it's just two people talking
and
that's that is a lot easier to
um mix and match with you know i had one
situation
with play shirts where i had a cast i
had a location
i tried to schedule it for six weeks the
actors could not
couldn't come up with dates and i was
just like all right
six weeks is long enough for me to keep
scheduling we're done i was just like
sorry everybody
i'm gonna shoot something else because
we can't seem to find a date
and life's short i didn't say that but
life is short
so i had another story in another cast
in three days and we shot the next week
so um
be willing to uh uh pull the plug on
stuff
don't be afraid to walk away from stuff
sometimes it's
sometimes it's better to walk away than
there's been stuff that i've been like
ah i'm just gonna put up with more of
this because it's gonna
eventually lead to some nothing else and
uh and it never did
ever it was just
you talked about endings where does the
story begin for you
how do you know you have a beginning of
a story
when you're sitting down to write or
you're at a coffee shop
i i
think it ideas kind of just find you and
track you down and
and um and sometimes they've run away
i i think with like bob berry's things
it was just a guy who buries things in
his backyard
and i knew what he was burying his
backyard and i didn't know why
so the story was why
for me so i
didn't know if i so i didn't have the
whole thing
at that point and then when i cooked it
i came up you know beginning middle and
end and
cooked up other characters and then
started diving in i want to know enough
where i'm going but not so much that i'm
not going to have any fun
you know if i outline the crap out of it
then i'm just like i'm just typing what
i did in the outline all the fun was in
the outline i want to just like
bare bones outline just here this
happens and this happens and this
happens
okay and then i can make everybody talk
and have fun hit those points
it's a lot easier to to do it that way
but i don't know how i
i don't know how i know if i have a
story i think it's it's
um i don't know it right away
um with clay shorts i wrote a bunch of
those at a theater in santa monica
um and four yeah in four hours so
i had to write that to be ready to be
rehearsed and then be on stage
in 10 hours so i had four hours to write
they had six hours to rehearse
and then it was on stage twice so i did
that like 40 times
so if you do that enough then so i sit
down i've got two people i know who they
are and i don't have their resume i just
have their headshots
so who are they what do they want what
do they do what do they want from each
other i would cook the whole thing
and i'd watch the other writers and the
other writers were tapping away like
right away and i'm with a legal pad like
for an hour like this and then oh and
then about this
and then once i have it all i'm like
okay so without that and that all right
and then i always start typing
because then i wouldn't have to rewrite
it because i think when you start
writing before you have
the bare bones of it you're just making
a big mess for you to fix
like no lie i made a big mess in the
book i wrote the book
i was close to where i knew the ending
was starting and i'm like something
doesn't feel right
i read the entire book and there's a big
dead spot
and i'm like this is but this is a red
herring this shouldn't take up this much
time
so i cut and paste just
that section i put another document it
was 14 000 words
i cut 11 000 words out of it and they're
gone they're nowhere else in the book
they're gone
because they didn't need to be there but
i didn't know that
until i could see the structure and i
knew this little part of the story
didn't need all this
but i didn't know it until i saw it was
kind of like you know if i wrote a
screenplay and i had a bunch of scenes
and that's kind of dry the movie kind of
drags at this point can we just cut
these scenes
it's that kind of thing but you don't
know it until you've got it built
and you can't have it built until you've
built it in your writing and it just
goes up and then when it's done
you're like oh the windows are all in
the wrong places you know then you got
to move it around
do it again is that why
riding on a legal pad for you is like a
better process because you're okay with
it being messy right there
yeah yeah and then when it goes into
sort of type format
you want it to be more in line and it's
like a signal to you well i think it's
it's um it's kind of it's not to
make it sound all like but it's kind of
like sketching before painting
you know it's kind of like let me draw
this out see what it's going to be
now i'm going to put paint on the canvas
so
if i if i know the bare bones of the
story
and i write with just the bare bones
then
other ideas are going to come in other
things are going to happen
sometimes i will find that my bare bones
are wrong
and that maybe i found a better bare
bone or maybe i find that
that bare bone there was one thing in in
bob berry's things
it was actually part of the 11 000 word
thing that i it was great you know
i never got to write like this it was
like oh wow i'm writing well i'm going
to describe
every inch of this room you guys are
going to know everything about this
it's going to be great
and then i'm like yeah this is just way
too much it's way too much you don't
need this
but you have to have some kind of fun
writing it's got to be some kind of like
it's a like i
enjoy it i never it's never hard i mean
it's sometimes hard to get going
but i 20 minutes
i look at the first 20 minutes as
warm up like i am i don't just sit down
and then oh what am i doing okay i open
up i kind of look at stuff
that's the great thing about having the
program read the book because then i can
sit back and have it read
the last chunk back to me and then it
kind of gets me into the
wrong then sometimes it'll i'll hear it
say like i use the word dome way too
many times look at the dome like five
times i'm like why am i saying dome
so much for someone's head yes
and i'm like an insider dome outside a
dome over a dome
honest dome top just dome dome dome i'm
like i get rid of these domes
but it's uh but you don't know until you
you have it
um and and again maybe it sucks
sorry what was the name of this program
uh scribner
oh okay i've heard of that yeah yeah
okay and so it will then
read back to you what you've typed oh
and it's a monotone
sort of yeah it's a voice it's just yeah
they they have put in breaths oh nice so
you can actually
hear the robot taking her breath here
and there and i think it reads
um things in quotes at a slightly faster
pace than
the other stuff so for dialogue i think
it does speed it up a little bit
but um yeah i definitely caught stuff
that
because i remember having i always had
table reads of everything for vampire
mob
and i would record it because i would
always catch stuff
when i listened to the recording and
then i did one i had a
screenplay called sue happy that the
filmmakers alliance um did a reading of
and they brought in
they had casting director they brought
in 25 actors it was a
giant ensemble thing it crushed uh
and it was the only time i ever got to
see one of my screenplays like almost
brought to life
like it was a staged reading but um
but it's that is the reason i think that
that'll be the next book because i know
i know what that story does to an
audience
so i know what it can do in book form
do you have a ritual for like okay
you've copied up
you're you're waiting is there like this
ritual to listen to the scrivener notes
yeah
uh well one thing i i always listen to
this i have a 9 i have an 8 hour and 49
minute long playlist of fats waller
songs
that's why i wrote a lot of songs um
and i have been listening to
that for over a decade um
because it i know all the music really
well
so i don't listen to it but it occupies
the part of my mind that can think of
something else to do
so i always have that on and only
i had to change to tool the band tool
for a sequence i was writing and i just
like i couldn't get it with fat's waller
i
never had any problem and i'm like i
need something a little i'm like
tool and it was perfect it was exactly
exactly what i needed but
uh yeah coffee water make sure to drink
water everybody it's important
and um headphones
and i always write at home i never write
in any
coffee shops or anything like that just
because i can close out enough the world
with
loud headphones and i have tinnitus so i
always hear ringing
uh 24 hours a day seven days a week so
um
when i have those on it there's
something about 1930s music that
that hits the frequency that buries my
tinnitus a little bit
wow except for when maynard sings
i don't know well
there's one tool song that's a little
much better
don't they have a new album yeah fear
inoculum
as to the pixies oh that's great
what makes a great story joe what makes
a great
story uh i think
i like roger ebert's uh
take on it it's when you don't remember
where you parked your car
i think that's really good yeah when
you're in
when you're in the theater and you're
watching the movie if you don't
if you can't think where your car is
parked that's a good movie
and i think uh for a story
it's different for everybody i mean
my wife watches stuff that i don't watch
and vice versa
and uh she loves the historical
drama stuff and i'm not so much with the
historical drama stuff
um but she and she's like it's just like
candy you know it's you know it's
romance and i'm like okay
that's great i don't want any candy i
guess i don't but
like i watch bob's burgers i love bob's
burgers
i think it's a great show
and it's really just a dysfunctional
family
it's all like every other classic sitcom
in the history of everything
and they just have a more grounded take
than the simpsons on
that genre was the brady bunch
dysfunctional
the brady munch on screen
i guess technically
sort of not not like now
i don't know because really
was really the beginning of like
anything close to truth getting on
television
so good times good time yeah it was
great all the normal air stuff
and they recently did a live reading or
live
reenactment and they built the sets and
uh jimmy kimmel had them do an episode
on the family an episode of the
jeffersons
and they had to bleep
part of it because you can't say that
word on tv anymore
and to hear all the stuff that rgb
bunker said that you can't say on tv
anymore and maybe it would be more
useful to hear it on tv now
so people could understand what a bigot
is right out of the gate
that's a good point because it was such
a great dynamic of
him playing off for getting me rob
reiner's character as the meathead
yeah and and this politically active
outspoken young person against
this old school bigot and then you have
the the codependent peacemaker edith
you know who just wants to make a map
and the thing is if you watch that show
there are episodes that don't leave the
living room
like that is doesn't happen a lot there
are a lot of shows that do that like
barney miller was one of those shows
that you know you'll have more than one
you'll have the work set and you have
the home set
on all the family was pretty much just
the living room in the kitchen once in a
while you'd see a bedroom
maybe the front porch and then maybe
go to the jefferson's once in a blue
moon but almost all of it
was like a stage play what about welcome
back cotter did they leave the class
yeah they did oh they did oh yeah here
and there they did yeah because i think
they did the hallways
let's go back through all the seven
issues
uh but i think barney miller was genius
just in terms of the setup
because you have because and that's sort
of the way i thought about vampire mob
was that if you
have kind of like a few main characters
and you rotate in all these other
characters you can build a really big
world and it's also
a lot easier to schedule because if you
can
you know i was having actors come in and
do four hours so
you would write so they could get what
you wanted done in four hours and then
if you can
set it up so they're doing more than one
day in the story day then they can show
up in more than one episode
and it changes the dynamics of the whole
thing
what was the first story that you ever
saw i guess television or
film or even that you read
where it lit a an idea sparks an idea
that this is what i want to do i want to
tell stories
you know i never thought i would wanted
to do any of this stuff
i thought i was going to be a
photographer and
never thought i'd write a story or
anything ever
i did i watched a ton of tv as a kid
for some reason i knew some tv
terminology i knew tag as a kid
i knew the tag in a sitcom because i
watched a lot of talk shows and
heard people talking about sitcoms and
said that last thing at the end is
called a tag that you do and i'm like oh
cool and so i'm like an eight-year-old
going oh that's the tag dad oh good
i don't care um but uh
i was i guess i was just sort of aware
what interested me was that
barney miller in was in new york city
and all the family was in new york city
good times of things for chicago um
taxi new york city taxi was new york
city i always thought i was going to
live in new york city growing up
i thought it would be a divorce man
living with another divorced man trying
not to drive each other crazy
but uh perfect strangers no no that's
uncoupled
but i guess i was just so aware that
they were shot here
as a kid like i would always watch it
all the way to the end because you were
waiting for the next show to start so
you'd see every single credit and then
you'd see
shot at abc television studio or cbs
television studios and i'm like
so all of that is not a new yorker when
you're a kid it's like
you know especially when when i'm an
hour i was growing up an hour and a half
north of new york and i'm thinking
oh barney miller he's just down just
down the train ride down in new york and
you sort of think of it that way and
then you think
oh so they have them all there and
they're in california where it's sunny
and they're pretending all this oh
that's interesting
joe we have a video we'd like to play
for you okay cue it up here
los angeles is a million
communities saying independent
storytelling is one thing
new media is one thing web series is one
thing it's so stupid there's no
mainstream in independent
within those categories is a billion
subcategories
and i'm a tiny little fragment of
nothing go go to my imdb page there's
nothing there
i'm nobody but the audience who knows
what i do
that's who i'm somebody to and that's
who i all i care about
because i don't yeah i don't get
i don't get hired by the audience and
fired by the audience
we have a i tell stories they help me
tell stories
pretty easy business plan again not for
everybody
sponsors you know they want that number
awards they want that number
but audiences they just care about
stories even
even if you tell stories with actors no
one's heard of is it a good story
how many stories have won oscars with
completely unknown casts
unknown directors that happens
it's not just what's number one at the
box office it's not the number one rated
show
you know again arrest development family
guy these shows that
got cancelled and are now coming back
after years of an audience
build that's the matrix that's the thing
that we can
we have over them we can tell a story
worldwide we can keep going we don't
have to have weekly ratings we don't
need to hit box office we don't need to
think about that we don't need to think
about awards
we can change the rules change the way
things happen
and not emulate all these past systems
new game
new way to do things new systems new
validation systems
all new individuals we each come up with
our own way to do it
our own individual business plans we
don't need
validation from anyone other than the
audience and you don't need that much
validation as an indie storyteller to
keep going
because if you're looking for an oscar
jesus you better
be eating carbohydrates every goddamn
day because that is a long run
and it's and it's an empty errand
i'd rather i'd rather entertain real
people
and hear from real people than please
some
unknown body of whatever so they say
good job
that's not real that's not
human
at all let's start with a fork
that was uh shot courtesy of nick's
coffee shop great place great setting
i love that we still i don't know this
was in 2013 i believe
so this is kind of cool to see in that
setting and
um i know they were very generous with
you to let you
shoot and do different things what's
your take on seeing
that video where you were
just your thoughts on creating stories
i guess uh i guess it was right about
all the stories that were coming because
now there's a billion of them
um i guess
i think the the thing about
um audience like now that i a bunch of
time has passed
like i have i've met so many people
internet neighbors who have helped me
tell stories at knicks and other places
[Music]
um
that's like that's why the audience is
their neighbors i think that the
the what i was saying about talking to
the audience i've been talking to the
audience for
years and so when
i'm telling a story i'm thinking about
people i know
who will either see it or read it and
it's
you know not know like you know no no
but
as far as you can know people on the
internet that's why
the term neighbor is
i don't know it's friends is a little
strong
i think and neighbors is a little more
like you know you have neighbors you're
friends with your neighbors but that's
that neighbor friendship where you're
like
you know you don't want to get in each
other's business too much
but everybody wants to get along it's
like that kind of thing and i think with
people that you know on the internet it
becomes sort of like that and and it
you build the social media neighborhood
that you want to live in
if you don't want to hear about all the
bad stuff then you filter all the bad
stuff and block those words and then
twitter can
you make a list that is exactly people
who don't piss me off that's a good list
to have
make that list so you can go on twitter
just
look at that list nothing bad's
happening on that list it's all nice
but the next thing that i when the book
comes out
and when the graphic novel comes out
because i've been talking to the
audience
to my neighbors in my neighborhood all
this time
it's inherently different than
if i was just filmmaker in marketing
mode on social media and all i do is
talk about
my project me my making a film my
my going to a film festival here's the
next
project blah blah yeah people are
interested in that but
i you know people know my cat
because i post my cat all the time and
does it have anything to do with
filmmaking
no do people have cats yes do people
i started a band with my cat called mike
and me
we don't make music because i don't know
how to play any instruments and he
doesn't have a thumb
so two of them even so we just make the
album covers
and and it's entertaining it's amusing
so when
i show up with something that's like
meaty
like here's a book then they're gonna be
like oh you wrote a book
cool joe wrote a book this guy that i've
been talking to for years
so different than hey
anybody want to read this book anybody
anybody is
now marketing now i'm advertising now
promoting
before it's just my neighbors
hey you guys want to want to come over
and see something i'm
um i made i'm going to project it up on
a sheet on the wall that's pretty much
what
it feels like and that you can fit a lot
of people
in in that room on the internet with
that sheet on the wall
because it's on the internet and it
again your stories can last
like uh i can't remember somebody told
me
oh i know it was um rupaul had a
has a game show i guess i don't see it
but has a game show and i
sold a jar of celebrity air in 2005 it
was a jar of air that was captured
within proximity to brad pitt and
angelina jolie
at the mr mrs smith premiere and made
international news it was on access
hollywood jay leno did a bit about it it
was
gigantic and somebody sent me a screen
grab
from rupaul's show and the question on
the bottom was
did someone sell a jar of air from brad
pitt and angelina jolie and it was
you know it was like last year and so
that was from 05
and so the i can't remember who told me
about it
when he sent me the screen grab he's he
said i said i'm amazed that people still
would even care about that because
angelina jolie and brad pitt they're
over and
he's like clever is forever oh and i'm
like clever
is forever i like that that's really
good
so i think that i think that you can
as an indie make small stuff
that is clever that maybe
people will look at down the line i made
a point to not
put references to current day time
i didn't want to use any current slang
i didn't want anything that would date
it so i made up my own slang there's
references to
man there's references to happy days
there's references to
it's a wonderful life like i pulled
slang from
everywhere because of that now it's its
own world it can't go bad
there's no reference to anything because
then people go oh i remember when that
happened oh this is old
and if they never reference anything
there's no there's no date on it you
don't know
they never say that's why i think you
know the advantage to telling stories in
the 80s now
is because nobody had a cell phone so
you can't text
now all your plot holes so many plot
holes i just
text yeah the whole show's over because
it's the 80s and i
i have this and i shouldn't have this i
can just i can
oh you want you need to talk to somebody
across town like okay
as opposed to driving to their house oh
they're not here you stay here and wait
and then i'll go and then
totally different story cleverest firmer
joe do you still believe that there will
be blue collar storytellers
or have they already arrived i think
they're already here
i think uh i think
that it's because whatever everything
that's gone on online
there is not um you know it
when there were less movies being made
they were worth more money for everybody
and there were also less jobs for
everybody there's never been more acting
jobs
in the history of everything than right
now there's never been more writing jobs
than right now
there's never been more directing jobs
than right now there's never been this
much stuff made
so i think there's a ton of
opportunities you know
in the industry because
there's so much being made and when
there's so much being made
it's a mass is inherently blue collar
it's not white color in that
white color like directors you know
directors are sort of the white color
worker when you
when when there's 50 of them
now it's just a bunch of people who
direct stuff so when you have all the tv
shows all the films
all the stuff that's online add up all
those jobs
add up all that you know again the the
guest star emmy consideration
performance number was
2 800 and something so
there were that many performances to
consider
so when you're in the thousands just for
an emmy consideration
just to get the nomination and
that is only getting bigger
there is no there the star system the
you know there's not going to be the
star directors
there's going to be like a billion sort
of
smaller known directors but i don't
think there's going to be you know
martin scorsese
i don't think that's i think it's going
to be less of that because there's
so much stuff i think you know there
will be voices that will be
you know distinct and original and
different
and there'll probably be more of those
voices because more stuff's being made
but um
because it's just like bird's eye view
in the 70s you made a movie
that's what people did there was nothing
else to do
you went to the movies or you watched
one of three networks or you read a book
read a magazine went for a walk that was
it
now i can sit home and watch the history
of film
on youtube if i want it is
ridiculous how much stuff is online so
saturation
naturally displaces
special so special
is is you know stars
and that kind of thing blue collar is
like there's a ton of people doing these
jobs now so
to be famous to be a star
i don't know there's famous people
but there's also a lot of famous people
we don't know because we don't watch
that show
and the show's been on for nine years
but still i've never watched big bang
theory still haven't seen it no idea
don't care and just like
there's sort of this middle class
squeeze you know especially
you know last few years in the us do you
think it's the same
with artists there's there's the blue
collar artists and there's a whole bunch
of blue collar artists
and then there's the white collar ones
and very little middle class
or i'm just making this up um i
yeah i don't i think would be more like
middle and then upper like i sort of
feel like if you're if you're working in
the industry and
you know making a living uh
you know most most of the people who
work on stuff are not
you know again it's a temp gig it's a
temp gig
and then when that temp gig ends you got
to get another temp kick so you can pay
the mortgage
and if you don't get another temp gig
and then you don't get another temp gig
after that and then
months go by then that's a problem um
but i i just i think there's going to be
less stars more famous people
not as famous um because
i've never i i've never seen this many
actors in my life i've never
even off the top of my head even knowing
just think of
just the tv shows and movies you've seen
in the last year
so much more than what would have been
watched in previous years because
the delivery system is the internet it's
what everyone else is doing it becomes
habit then we're talking about it online
it becomes behavior
and that was the thing when you're
trying to get people to change their
behavior from watching a tv show at a
certain time on a certain
day and then you were getting changing
their behavior by here's the entire
season watch it
and then that behavior changed like all
the
ten years ago all the web series people
were saying oh yeah five minutes is too
long
five minutes is way too long no one's
gonna watch five minutes no one has time
to watch five minutes you're an idiot if
you're making something
it should be three minutes that's how
long as much time people have
and and and they were all wrong
uh yeah some people want to watch three
minutes but in terms of like an
overarching
philosophy on human behavior no
wrong what human beings will do is sit
down and watch 12 hours of television
because it's brand new and they want to
be able to talk about stranger
things at the office on monday
new behavior
so remind me again what a blue collar
artist is blue collar screenwriter blue
collar director i guess blue color is
is uh less known
less you know more scrappy not
necessarily scrappy
i think it's literally just from
saturation because in the 70s if you had
the number of movies that came out in a
year and the number of tv shows that
came out in 1975
and you added them all up and now
everything that came out in 2018
and you added them all up it would be a
skyscraper and be a little too
two-story building here's 1975 here's
now
all these movies and tv shows and actors
so when you have this much
i'm a director really what did you
direct well it's only this much
because it's 1975. it's not that hard oh
you directed something
what did you direct everybody there's a
lot of stuff to pay attention to
when there's a lot it becomes less
special less
valuable less less it becomes less
because there's
so much you don't feel like it's it's
like the kid
who has one toy and the kid loves that
toy
because the kid only has one toy and
then there's the kid
who's got aunts and uncles who has been
burying that kid and every toy
the kids got every toy none of them are
special because there's a million of
them
you only have that one that's special so
when you have you know a handful of
people who were allowed
to make movies and that could now it's
that it's a bigger pile of people
there's way more and it's
less precious it's less special you know
honestly no one gives a about the
oscars
not that they really gave a that
much before but if you look at the
reality of box office
oscars are not
catering to the public they are catering
to
the academy because when the streaker
came by
well that was too good but i mean they
were streakers
yeah but but that idea of you know
the oh it's an oscar winning special
you know it's it's scarcity
there isn't that scarcity so if it's not
scarce if it's not
special if there's so much
then it's it turns into blue collar it
turns into
a lot of people are doing this at the
factory
they're all making these things so i
mean blue collar and
they may make a living that is white
collar they may you know their job maybe
you know maybe they're not dragging
cables around uh
and that kind of thing maybe they're
doing something you know
nicer but it's
less special and i think it's good that
there's that that happened i think it's
gonna
i think it will make the industry better
what about if people say well
why should i bother i'm not gonna stand
out is standing out at an archaic
it's constantly yeah i think it's
standing out your goal then
or my project's not going to stand out
well i mean
sometimes good projects get buried you
know it's really hard to control the
world
and what you're doing you know again the
movie was recently buried because of all
the mass shootings because they knew
marketing wise that was a bad
move um
if if
you can as a filmmaker storyteller
artist whatever it is that you create if
you can
find five people who like what you do
and you talk to them on a regular basis
and they
tell other people about what you do then
that
audience grows and it grows naturally
grows
organically grows slowly
and the quality of the that
group of individuals who knows who you
are
that changes i think what you make and i
think it changes
you because you know kind of
who it is that's going to be looking at
your stuff because you talk to them
on a regular basis like i know
stuff about people and people are going
through stuff and they're internet
neighbors
you know i know more people online than
i do offline
way more they're all over the place
but it's um
and i do you know the we're all famous
to a few people thing is
is the reality of saturation is
how many people does it take for you to
be famous
how many people have to know who you are
to be famous
the weatherman in minneapolis is very
famous
in minneapolis he's going to walk into
an applebee's and everybody's going to
go the weather man's here
that guy shows up and here nobody gives
a
they don't know who he is because he's
famous in that little group the little
silo it's like like the huge band in the
uk right now that none of us know
because we're not in the uk
but they're huge over there wolf alice i
don't know
but that's what i mean there's always
one yeah the little silos you know all
the korean k-pop stuff all that
that is another silo right uh i do a
live streaming music show on wednesdays
and
people stay up i'm amazed like
netherlands uk like it's two o'clock in
the morning
we do one show and so people make
requests from
essentially when they tweet a youtube
link with a hashtag all i do is follow
the hashtag i click on the youtube link
and i play their request and then
everyone listening votes
and if they don't like the song then i
stop the song
so it's called song request cage match
so it's like
yours bring your song and see if it gets
beat up or not
and so in australia someone requested
something
and there was another australian who's
also
on and the two of them are going back
and forth about the song and they're
going on and on and on about it i'm like
i've never heard of this song i have no
idea who this guy is i
know and they're like oh it was
everywhere and that's what i mean
like those little tiny silos
of you know it's like the people who are
really into game of thrones and people
are really into
one particular comic book
that nobody else you know and if you're
not into it you don't know about i was
at a barbecue and some guy walked up to
me it's like hey do you watch game of
thrones i was like no
all right i can't talk to you do you
watch game of thrones and
i'm like i'm not going to feel bad
because you want to find something to
get all excited about the finale with
but that's those silos
so when somebody says hey have you ever
seen the seen this vampire mob
thing well that was vampire mode this
thing just watch it's hard to explain
that's them telling somebody else about
your work that
them saying i like this i think you
might like this
that is the best marketing in the world
and you can't make that happen you can't
force that to happen you can't just show
up and crowdfund and make that happen
and you also can't
show up on crowdfunding and then never
crowdfund again and then
and disappear seen that i've bought
literally while i was
looking up a documentary and i
tripped over some segments of it on like
vimeo and i went back to their twitter
and i and their twitter literally was
we've reached our goal
and there was one more tweet and they
never tweeted again
and i was like wow that is some
hardcore opportunistic crowdfunding
because
you're not even going to say anything
past the we hit the go
we're out do they make the film
it's not out parts of it are out
um it's been too long
i'm guilty of that myself with one of my
crowdfunding things so
maybe something went wrong but uh
yeah that's that's that's bad
filmmaking that may not be
actually shooting but if you are going
to crowdfund and then stop
talking the day you make your goal or
the day after you make your
goal you're doing it wrong
you need to keep talking those people
forever
because then it's going to come out then
you're going to do something else
and i've i i've talked to someone who is
a
big supporter of mine who has
contributed to everything i've ever
crowdfunded for and she told me that of
a couple of people who i know
online who she had contributed to
and she said you know i never got any of
my perks
ever from any of those projects you're
the only project that i've always got my
perks from
and i'm like really and she said yeah i
don't want to you know say anything but
they show up and ask for more money and
they didn't give me the perk from the
last
one that's bad filmmaking
sorry because you're doing it to make
films
and if you're crowdfunding and then you
do that
you're screwing over your audience
you're you're
not authentic you're ingenuine you are
you're exploiting people you're taking
advantage
and you're an
what's something about storytelling you
wish that you had learned earlier
in your career or you wish you'd stuck
your guns on maybe people tried to talk
you out of it
i guess i wish i knew
how much how much more important
character development was to writing i
think that was
i don't think i developed the characters
enough when i started writing
and i think that's where i
if i had if i'd known to take more time
to develop the characters i think i
would have
less or would have had less of a
challenge
in either the writing or the rewriting
especially the rewriting
because i think when you you've got a
draft you're going through it you're
looking for the problems
you see the problems and
[Music]
sometimes the solution is
in the bio of the character it's
something that you
you haven't put on the page but it's
something about them
and and and so the answer is already
there because you did your homework
before you start writing the script so
that that's one thing i wish i knew
and in terms of sticking to my guns
i
when i i have i probably have stuck to
my guns
to a fault um
i i'm one thing i'm really bad at is
tolerating fools
and there are a lot of fools uh in the
entertainment industry
in every industry but i think more in
the entertainment industry
special breed of fool um in what way
um i guess
because they're there's very little
much like people call themselves experts
and
the only thing that makes them an expert
is that they put the word expert in
their bio
and there's no you know it's not like
you
get a doctorate or something you know
you say like i'm a social media expert
really that so you must spend all of
your time learning about the new social
media thing to do
and that's all you're doing um
going off on a tangent i it's a good
tangent
yeah um
well you said sticking to your guns to
your detriment you don't think that
that's a good thing sometimes
when you're the writer you're the
employee and sometimes
uh i have
not often not that many gigs to begin
with but
a couple of times i was writing
something that was stupid
and i knew it was stupid and
but the people who were
producing the project who brought me on
had success previously
and and they were convinced this was
going to be their next one
and and i was the guy to do it and
and it was a horrible idea that i
explained to them what the
why it was a problem and the chara
the main character wasn't likable in a
way that
would make the audience would never make
the audience care
about the character and so i had to cook
up like this
whole other thing and then explain to
them like we
this we need to root for the character
and if the character
is um i remember
whoopi goldberg told the story of
writing a screenplay
about a
hardcore right-wing republican senator
who finds out that he has black blood in
his lineage and all of his politics
would make that bad and
uh i can't remember who she went to for
advice
and the person gave them the advice yeah
just throw it out
uh and they were like this is a great
idea we have a lot of interest and
people are
yeah who cares who cares what happens
to this republican guy he's a bad person
who discovers
that he's an even worse person like why
are we going
and and the these two producers their
argument was
well you know bill murray in groundhog
day he's very unlikable i'm like yeah
yeah your main character is female so
name me
one mainstream comedy that has an
unlikable female lead
in the history of film
and nobody could come up with one
because it doesn't
work you have to have there has to be a
reason
and and bill murray is bill murray
so you already have you know that
character if that was an
unknown and being unknown with all
unknown cast
that movie would be a harder read
because
he makes that character fun and likable
and another actor might not be able to
do that as well
um yeah and and the thing is it was it
was a horrible idea and to the best of
my knowledge it's never been made
not surprising so you're saying that
working
on characters flushing them out
backstory
was something you wish you had learned
earlier because you said before that you
would go on this legal pad
so that mount that must have been well
that was something i learned yeah when i
first
the first screenplay i wrote was based
on a real life situation that i cooked
the story around it wasn't comedy and it
wasn't
i was based on a hit and run that i was
stopped from photographing by the police
and it was a cover-up and
[Music]
so that the character i it was all plot
it was no it was very little character
and
and it was a just a house of cards plot
too
because that's what you know when you
build up this sort of mystery and
and you have this house of cards and you
like oh i need i need to change that one
thing because that's not gonna work and
then you realize that that is connected
to all these other things
and i'm like oh if i change this and i
have to rewrite everything
that is a nightmare if i had the
characters already cooked more
then it would be i think easier to go
into the character bio and the character
mind and look at the plot from that
point of view
rather than being sort of like god
here's the plot here do something
come on character do something it
doesn't work
so it was something i learned and that's
where the legal pad
came from because then it was like i can
scribble i can write whatever i want now
this matters no one's ever
going to see this and that's the other
thing to keep in mind is when you're
writing
no one's going to see until you show it
to them enjoy that
but we want to show it to them oh you
want to show it to him but enjoy it when
you have
it because when it goes out for notes
it's
something else and then it goes out for
more notes and
and it gets torn apart and it's only
yours when you're writing it
and then you give it and then it gets
and it comes back and you
write it and glue it back together and
how's this
do it again until everyone's happy most
likely except you
at least that's been my experience
how long have you been in los angeles 22
years
and in a couple of months a month a
couple months i'm leaving
forever
not by choice but uh some family members
need some help and my wife and i are
going to be that help so
i'm leaving los angeles the place i've
lived the longest actually
my whole life so how does that feel to
you do you
is it sort of like you're seeing those
years flip by in your mind like a tv
show like it's
i is a combination
of uh regret
and uh i think kind of the realization
that
maybe things not working out for me in
the entertainment industry maybe was for
the best
uh because i think the timing of how
[Music]
if i if the success came the way i
thought it was going to
come at the time that i thought it was
going to come
[Music]
when spec sales were huge and
people made money fast
[Music]
i uh
i guess i i feel like i've just
gone through like the longest training
program
anybody could ever go through to learn
how to do a bunch of
um i didn't know how to direct or
write or act or do stand-up
the way i do now from having done it
sitting down to write a book having
done all these different things made the
writing
easier and better and and all that stuff
because i've been doing it
um i
you know i i wanted to come here and be
successful and buy my wife a house
didn't happen so
when things don't work out the way you
want then you
improvise adapt and overcome and that's
what i'm going to do moving to albany
new york which is not
a entertainment capital that i know of
[Music]
but locations will be easier to get
i do have a line on actors uh placer
which is something i can continue doing
uh graphic novel has i don't know how
many more
issues in it um
i guess i had a lot of fun
i met a lot of people uh
some of it was not fun
but uh i guess overall
i wouldn't have done it any other way
because i had to know like i had to know
what was going to happen you said
regrets earlier
oh yeah what were the regrets oh god
too many to number uh
i guess i should have tolerated some
fools more
and
[Music]
yeah a bunch of stuff
but aren't you glad that forgive me i
don't know where you were before you
went to boston
yeah okay but were you still in uh what
if you had stayed in upstate new york
and or gone back i don't know you know
what
your travel line was and you worked for
a company
and they pushed you out the door because
they're hiring people from oh sure
somewhere else or they're closing that
plant or something
so that essentially happened to the
company uh that i
was working for in boston i was very
lucky that
the company i had a day job with in
boston had a company out here
so when i i said i'm moving to los
angeles if you guys want me that's where
i'm going to be and they were like
you can work in the other company's
office for boston so i had a job
that i flew with so that was great
um and then they pulled the plug on the
company fired everybody
once i got out here
um but
what was the question so i guess the
question is
what if you hadn't come here wouldn't
you be more regretful
for had not because you're you're still
with your wife
oh yeah i'm not trying to get too
personal but i mean some people don't
oh yeah every time all the time you know
what i'm saying i'm
i know people have died you know
in pursuit of this uh some people died
from suicide
some people died from drugs overdose
some people died from
[Music]
lifestyle you might say and
uh i
guess i guess what i
didn't know and there's no way you
really could know
like i did stuff in boston and
it you know it was done live there's no
you know this video of it but
most of the time it was like it was
theater it was something that was done
for a live audience and that's what it
was meant
to do and then when it was over it ended
and that was it
it didn't exist anymore except for in
the minds of the people who saw it
i've heard from people who remember the
stuff i did in the 90s
when i was in boston uh performance art
stuff installation
art and like all that stuff is gone none
of it exists
anymore uh but they remember it
and you know if you
make a movie and it's successful and a
lot of people see it and they'll
remember
it sometimes movies become a part of
people's lives they buy the dvd
they watch it on a regular basis uh
something on the background
it's the movie they go to when they're
feeling shitty uh
that is uh
something i sort of got to experience
with vampire mob that
you know i did have people contact me
who said that they
you know life wasn't great and they were
kind of down and
they enjoyed the humor and the
characters and the story in it
and it gave them some place to go for a
while and that's
why i feel like to some degree
storytelling
is a service you are in service
of other people stories are for other
people
and that's who you're creating for
i mean you could create for yourself but
if they don't see it then it doesn't
exist
what do you think that you should have
tried more of or maybe
maybe there's nothing you know
i changed directions a bunch of times uh
when things weren't going right i'm like
you know when things with acting and
stand up weren't going great
and i was looking at writing
screenwriting and i hadn't written
anything and i'm like
man do i have a learning curve and i'm
like i gotta back up everything else
take classes really focus on
on screenwriting and and learn
everything that i can about it and i've
lost the question again
um what do you think that maybe you
should have tried
i guess
i probably should have um
i think i should have kept doing
stand-up i think i could have should
have
kept spreading myself out then the way i
was
and find uh finding ways to
deal with that chaos
which i enjoyed to some degree um but
the more i met a lot more people doing
stand-up
um and when you're a writer you meet
less people because you're
at home writing and i was in a few
writer's groups and there were always a
nightmare i
just it was almost like competitive
notes like
oh yeah you didn't like my screenplay
wait till i give you notes on yours
it was garbage i remember one screenplay
that this guy wrote and had very
specific terminology
to the x games to all these special
things you do on a skateboard on a bmx
bike and all this stuff
and i'm reading it and i'm like yeah i
don't know what any of this is and he's
like well that's the language that they
use that's the thing i'm like yeah but
what does that mean what does they what
do they do
well all you have to do is say that and
people know what it is yeah but the
person at the
reading the at the studio the agent
they're not going to know this
oh i'm sorry i'm telling you information
you don't want to hear
i can oh so this isn't feedback you just
want to be
you want you just want to be told this
is good you don't want to make it better
you just want to so then and then when
it was time for my
my screenplay to be read he just was
like anything he could find
and and you you know i know what good
feedback is and what is not good
feedback and that was
revenge feedback
what advice would you give to someone
else leaving los angeles
hmm i wouldn't
give them any advice i guess uh
yeah i kind of uh
sometimes advice is uh
just someone else's version of the way
they think things should work
and and it's just uh
it's just another obstacle it's just
it's a it's a your expectation is being
managed by someone else's experience and
their experiences and necessarily what's
going to be your experience so
the advice has no value
because they're well the way i did it
well yeah
the way you did it is and and that was i
think
one of my problems was that i was trying
to i saw how other people made it and i
was trying to do it the way they did it
i was okay so you do this and then you
win a contest and then you get a manager
and then you go out take a script out
and then you sell it
and uh
there's a million ways careers happen
and don't
make the mistake i did of sort of
telling your story you're
like well this is going to happen then
i'm going to do this this and this and
this and that's the way it's going to be
and then when it's not oh i did
something wrong
i guess i'm the problem so i gotta
change the plan
so i'm not gonna do this this and this
and all right that's not working
i'm gonna it
i i enjoyed less of it
i missed out on a lot
because i was working so hard
to try to make it what did you miss out
on
oh birthdays vacation
seeing the outside world friendships
a lot a lot
you can only sit in one chair at a time
what does success look like to you
i don't know anymore actually
that is a good question
nothing to do with the entertainment
industry
well you'll still be able to make
stories oh yeah and and now you might
have a pool of people
that oh sure aren't going to be you know
there's going to be access to
talent up there as well yeah and maybe
something new will come from it and
it'll be a new definition of
because i think coming being here we're
so clouded by
not the middle class version of success
oh yeah but this like
astronomical thing that i don't even
know if those people are happy we don't
know that
we don't know if that's i have met a lot
of people who were
wealthy and successful and miserable
i remember talking to somebody who had
they were working on a basic cable show
and a network show at the same time
and they were complaining that the basic
cable show didn't send a driver
and then the network show did it was you
know why doesn't the basic cable show
sent to driver and i was just like
i'm in the back of my mind going you
know how many people would like
to have that problem
not having the basic cable show send a
driver oh you have to drive yourself to
your job that you could poor you
you're bricking my heart it's like
listen to people who like social media
experts who complain about traveling
they're like oh my god it's so hard to
travel from conference to conference and
miss flights and all the rest of it
really
get up on a roof and do some roofing in
august in los angeles
get the smell of tar up in your nose and
then tell me how hard it is again to sit
in an airport
really is it really that hard to sit in
an airport sorry
sorry you have to sit so long sorry
that's such hard work for you
sorry you're not at the hotel where
you're supposed to be at the right time
again get on a roof in
august with a smelly tar in your nose
and tell me again how hard it is that
you work
writing's not hard none of this is
hard
none of this is roofing in august
in los angeles anytime you think you're
working hard
think oh well you know what i'm not on a
roof in 95 degrees
with tar up my nose that's hard work
all the rest of this you know i worked
hard but i didn't do
roofing for the last 22 years you know i
was indoors
it was not hard work i've seen artwork
i've been about hard work i've done hard
work
none of this is hard work hard work
is a bunch of 18 hour days on set day
after day after day that is hard work
hard work gaffers do hard work
electricians do hard work carpenters do
hard work
actors less so director's lesson
so i never wanted to be a video village
director i never wanted to be the guy
sitting looking at monitors and
barking from a chair i wanted to be
holding a camera and i wanted to be
right in there with the actors
because that's where it is happening
and if i didn't know how to run a camera
then i couldn't have done that so i
learned how to run a camera so i can do
that
and i'm a better director because i run
camera
because i'm there i'm with the actor the
actor's looking at me the director who's
operating the camera that's pointing at
them
completely different experience and the
guy over in the corner
who's barking stuff back or gets up
walks over says something walks back
i just yell cut good anything all right
again go
i can shoot 10 pages in four hours door
to door in and out done it every time
every episode of play shorts was four
hours
rehearse the actors for two hours a week
before
bring them in we walk into knicks at
four o'clock
we set up lights we eat dinner we
shoot we close it up 9 9 30 we're gone
four or five hours all you need
don't eat an 18-hour day and you don't
need a giant crew
any thoughts on um friendships in la
partnerships
friendships in l.a are
sometimes friendships are based on
projects there's a lot of project
friendships like you work on a project
and everybody's
friends and you can know each other
forever and then the project is you
never see each other again
uh that's pretty common and then you're
right it's like
co-worker friendships it's that kind of
thing um
i think it is harder to have or at least
it was i found it harder to
[Music]
have more meaningful friendships
just at the
the pace of everything that was going
and
everyone's so worried about their career
and who's got what who's doing what and
the next thing that it
it um didn't allow for a lot of uh
um deeper friendships
i felt but some of that's me
so and some of that delay
so is it about the work for me it was
always about the work i really
you know i really loved it
and i wish i could have done it more
but
i didn't
what's the thing you're most proud of
the thing i'm most proud of
nothing that's on screen i don't think
i'm
i think i'm more proud of what i
what i knew
that i got through it
i guess not any specific work it's sort
of the
all of it my
all those classes
workshops and writers groups and
meetings
with managers and contests oh
christ
i could have made a lot more money doing
something else
but it wasn't i moved out of here for
the money because i was doing
you know the non-profit art thing in
boston
and there's
something about the uh
there's something about making art
when you know it's not going to make you
any money
that is different when
you know i mean people oh i paint and i
put up in a gallery and people pay me
thousands of dollars
yeah most painters don't have that most
painters are
they got a lot of paintings and that
haven't sold
and i think
when i did an installation that had
uh 27 tvs in it and
uh things were run by motion detectors
and there were vcrs and slide projectors
and took up a giant room and
it took me 50 hours to put it up and i
had help
and i was in that gallery for a week and
almost slept on the floor one night i
was there so long
and i knew i wasn't gonna make a dime
from it knew it
knew it cost me money to do it knew i
wasn't gonna make a dime
but i had to do it i had to do it i had
to make it
i it was the first thing i ever made it
was
huge and
uh i showed it once
i never showed it again and
that thing changed everything
if i didn't do that thing i wouldn't be
sitting here talking to you right now
because i know the dominoes that went
over
because of that one thing i made
so
when you make something
[Music]
that is for commerce that is that is the
goal
commerce is the goal and it doesn't sell
then it's not a success
and and that is it's a business
that is people don't get paid if you
don't make money
uh art is you know i got grants i got
you know i worked at day jobs to pay for
all the stuff so i could have the time
to
make the art um
and all the and the the reward was
seeing people go through it hearing
from people afterwards like that was
enough
and
when i started doing stand-up and
performance art
and dealing with doing a little bit of
touring
with a with two different shows um
i that's when you know i got things got
to get paid for
you know i got to pay for all this stuff
so this has to make at least this much
money to pay for this much stuff and if
i'm going to get
in if i'm going to get paid it's going
to be above these costs
they when you're out here in los angeles
in the entertainment industry
you're not making anything that is not
made for money
um that is the goal that's it's a
business you're not making art
you're making commerce you're making
product
and yes there's some creativity in it
but if nobody wants it
nobody wants nobody cares well you've
written a great screenplay that no one
will ever make that no one wants
there's lots of people who have i've
done definitely done a couple of those
but uh so the value of it
is like screenplays are not
to be read they're maps for movies if
they're not made into movies then
they're not
then they don't exist they're nothing
they're not there's
screenplays literature there's not
people sitting around hey
we had a good screenplay yesterday it's
so good
that's ridiculous um
but
the i think the thing with the internet
neighbors
who have a response to my work is
similar to seeing human beings have a
response to my work in a gallery and
[Music]
i started as a photographer so it was
just a picture on a wall
or in front of them or in a newspaper
magazine
and then when it was installation i
surrounded
the viewer sound light
images physical objects
um a structure that changed the space
and then i started doing performance art
because the same thing i could control
i they were sitting there i was sitting
here and i could
create something that we could all that
could have we could
it could happen together and
you would experience it your way and and
i'm and we're all here together
this is what's happening and yeah you
paid a ticket
to get in here but it's barely going to
cover the cost of doing this
show uh
that is very similar to when i make
shorts and i put them online and i hear
from people who
who saw them it's the value
[Music]
the value is the experience that you're
creating for someone else in whatever
media
so you know stand-up comedy your job is
to make people laugh
so that's your job if you're telling
somebody a story it's a funny story not
a funny story
it has to keep them amused and engaged
and interested
and when it's uh
art
i think you don't think exactly the same
way
i think it's i think it is a little more
of the uh i'm making art and you're
gonna
see it and
the relationships i think different a
little bit
yeah just thinking of like cindy sherman
you know and and whether i mean i know
she got a lot of criticism for some of
the work that she did but i just found
her so fascinating
yeah yeah just just especially the time
in history that she was doing
her work compared to now when everyone's
taking selfies left and right
right right such a weird and also just
the reality that people
are more comfortable in front of lenses
there's going to be entire generations
now that have no problem being in front
of the camera
or just living for life in front of the
camera not even being able to enjoy an
event
having to show having to document it yep
selfie museums and that's all cool
that's great
but at some point you're not really in
reality though
right people are going to movies and
they're texting during the movie
why would you pay for a ticket is it for
the air conditioning and somewhere to
sit
right and that and and and that's what
makes going to the movies
unattractive to people
like it has to be marvel it has to be
loud in action
so everyone's attention is on the screen
and not on the other screen they have in
their pocket
and if the movie's not good enough to
keep your attention from texting
then maybe it's not moving
or maybe
we need more it's like a drug and so
what it's not enough to just have good
dialogue anymore
a great interesting scene between two
people we'd become too desensitized to
it
well i don't know if all of us have but
i think they're definitely you know
there's
it's like pop music pop music is
inherently shitty music
not all of it but a lot of it except for
the song pop music that's actually good
so pop music is you know it's
it's uh it's short it's
catchy it's got some part that you can
sing along with or come along with or
whatever it's got some little
chorus hook thing in it someone's been
jilted yeah exactly
and i think it's i think it's the
same to some degree with with movies
uh that are popular is that you know
it's just meant as this little thing
that you see and it comes and goes and
and that's it it's very and then there's
other movies that maybe have a bigger
impact um i don't know
i really think about the audience
audiences now
so many people are watching stuff alone
you know with a laptop or on their phone
or you know if you're on a plane
everyone's
watching a movie on something
and that is the more normal behavior now
than
to have the sort of communal experience
at a theater where you're
you're all laughing at once or you're
all jumping at once and now it's just
you
and i think as a storyteller i
like now i never think about a theater i
never think about a group of people
watching i always think about one person
yeah i never think about a group i used
to think about groups of people when i
was writing and now i think about one
person
especially writing the book i definitely
think about one person because that is
the only way it works
but even with yeah even with the other
stuff i would say that's true
what are things you learned in the last
five years that you wish you knew
the first five years you were here god
i'm
thinking of all these negative things
uh uh let's see uh
it can be reality based it doesn't
happen people lie
and you will be amazed at how much they
will lie
who they are when they're lying and what
they're lying about
um five years ago i guess i didn't
know how
much of a
an impact i've had a tiny impact i've
had
on a bunch of people i know online um
i didn't know i don't like the term
influencer and i don't consider myself
an influencer because it
sounds really let me come and influence
you
just um and not the c word either not
the secret content creator yes
but i uh yeah i think that's
one thing uh so people lie you didn't
know the type of
impact that you had on people that were
let's say
well even online even like doing the
film courage interviews
you know seven years ago and then i pop
back in and read the comments and i'm
like
i did why said what i did what really
well that's i'm glad i inspired you but
man um it's very nice
but i didn't know i could do that
uh ever um
so i guess that would be a third thing
um
i don't know i did not know how
up the country was
like i i was always you know uh
painted as a pessimist when i pointed
out the
things about the country that seem so
obvious now
that have always been there but yeah
um i
guess last five years i think that's
three and a half months i guess
i didn't know that people would like my
cat so much online
i don't know that's something i didn't
know
that i wish i knew i would have made my
cat much more
of a prominent figure in my work
but it's cool to see sorry to interrupt
but the two of you together though it's
not just your cat i mean mike's adorable
and he's great you know he's takes a
great photo
but my photography professors would be
like
what are you doing like literally i
remember one class he was like
i do not want to see any pictures of
cats
or wrought iron fences those are the two
things i do not want to see in this
collage
and now i'm just taking cat pictures um
but it's the two of you together you did
something about like investigating some
kind of catnip ring
oh yeah which was hilarious oh yeah you
were like it was like sort of
investigative journalism
and it was like i don't know if it was
like bad catnip or what it was
yes but you were you were on it yeah um
this guy i know that lives in glasgow
scotland had a fake news show and he had
uh reporters uh all in different
countries that were all doing stuff
and so i came up with
uh i was using the opioid epidemic but i
just switched it to catnip
and then made everything about catnip
and tried to interview my cat
yeah that yeah that was a lot of fun
[Music]
i guess i wish i
knew how much more important having fun
was like it didn't
s fun doing the work like
like i know i've never had a bad time
directing
like even when it was things didn't go
right it still was
really fun um
[Music]
i really like working with actors so i
always
you know run quick easy fun sets it's
you know there's no there's no
man there's no
not on my sides at all um
and i guess the other thing i learned
is that sometimes i probably learned
this before five years ago
but sometimes somebody who is
hungry and wants to work on something
is better than someone who has a resume
who can prove they'd be great to work on
it
sometimes i've definitely worked a
couple of times i've worked with people
who uh it was their first time shooting
something it was my first time shooting
something and none of us should have
been shooting that and it all worked out
fine
like it was just like i was not gonna i
need a dp
we have to have a director of
photography there's no way that we can
shoot this without i was just more like
so you can focus right you know you
could shut a couple of things with your
dslr okay can you do this can you do
this
can you and it worked out perfectly it
was odd that we ended up with
three access to three five ds
three uh operators and we had three
identical lenses
that were um it's a 28 to 70
uh l series lens that just
gorgeous just does great stuff and
somehow
one person had another one one person
could borrow one and
so we had matching cameras with matching
lenses
[Music]
for the whole shoot it's the only thing
i used 2870.
quote from you it's all about the
audience when you tell stories to agents
managers and producers
that doesn't happen i guess the way
audiences experience
stories just like uh regular people
uh you know they have emotional response
there's
disbelief is suspended um
when you're telling a story to people in
the business
they're it's it's almost like
everyone in the industry is a magician
and you have a magic trick and
they all know already know how the trick
works because they're
they work in the magic business and so
they always look at tricks
like a magician not like an audience
member
and so your agents your producers all
the rest of it they can't
experience it the same way because they
have been
paying too much attention to how tricks
work that they can't suspend their
disbelief and just
see the trick and go oh wow how'd you do
that
the marketing part of like if you're
writing a story and it's a really good
story
and it is um not marketable it's
probably
going to be harder to get made um
if something is marketable and it's a
good story
it might be easier to get made
but i think i've made
this mistake sometimes i think you can
be too focused
on trying to write to the market i think
you can be
like a friend of mine who's like all
into whatever the
new thing is that people are into
and they will then chase that genre
um and it's i don't know it seems like
an empty errand to me it seems like
you're
you're chasing your tail because if you
can recognize
a trend then it's already over because
by the time
you're jumping on that trend it's
it'll be done and like when i
i wrote a vampire show at the height of
all the vampire
uh not out of marketing just out of well
if everyone likes these
vampire shows and i don't like any of
them um
can i have one that i like and so that
was
that's vampire mod vampire mop was a
show that i would like
uh and i and it
people continue to find it and and it
also i think
people's perception changed because
there aren't a million vampire stories
now
so when they see vampire mob now it's
different than it was ten years ago
and that's kind of cool like time
changes
the story
what do you need right now what do i
need right now
hmm uh patience
time and
[Music]
cash okay
in that particular order maybe well
[Music]
yeah probably yeah
mostly in that order yeah it takes a lot
to
pack up 22 years of your life and move
it 3000 miles
i did it i was in boston for 13 when i
moved down here
so and i you know i couldn't i threw a
lot of art away i couldn't take all my
installations
i couldn't take any of it no way and i
couldn't store it because i didn't have
the money
so it i literally threw art in a
dumpster
so i could move here that'd be crazy if
somebody found it and they still have it
in their apartment
you never know it's true it'd be weird
for them to have it
what do you think you needed when you
first came here
in 97 98 you said 1997.
um
i don't know
i don't know i think uh i would
all i was looking for was some kind of
validation that i was doing the right
thing i think
and rarely if ever got it
i think the that is also kind of a
wasted
you know it's great when people like
your stuff
and just people in the industry like
your stuff it's very nice
[Music]
and sometimes
they uh
maybe you like it a little too much
um how's that possible uh
because they're trying to sell you on
how much they like it
so they need something from you no it's
more like
they're
it's they're telling you how great you
are sometimes
not everybody but i've had a few times
where
um i'm trying to zero in on this
and i lost it is it because they want to
be cast in their next project i mean
like when a manager talks like a lit
manager talking up
talking up your project to you to try to
essentially don't believe the hype like
sometimes
had a couple of managers who
[Music]
and that's part of their job they want
to keep you psyched and that's
nice but try not to believe the hype
whether it's your the hype that they're
they're like hyping you
they're they're like it's gonna do this
and just gonna do that and you're
you know and that's all great but
if you really believe it uh
you're going to be greatly disappointed
and i think
that's that's the hard thing
when you're you know
[Music]
when people move out here it's like you
know you
give up a lot and the industry becomes
your most important relationship and
everything that's the
first thought in your head and
everything else comes in second
and that's uh
not the way everybody does it that's the
way i did it um because i was just so
i'm like i'm going to make this work i'm
going to
make this i'm going to force this to
happen and
i couldn't i couldn't force it to happen
and then after a while it wasn't fun and
then
when it wasn't fun and i just like i'm
just going to do my own
and i'd more maybe more entertainment
industry meetings
when i ignored the entertainment
industry than when i didn't
uh because people treat you differently
when you make stuff
when you're a writer it's just oh you
got some stuff on a paper good for you
isn't that nice but when you make stuff
and people oh you made
oh you're a director oh you actually
wrote and directed you made something
people treat you differently it's a
totally different vibe
then here i have this i'm going to make
this so good that's
if you've made some stuff even if it's
just shorts
but the how stuff made changes you know
changes you as a writer changes you as a
director
editor like i i know why i was
rewritten so a lot more having been an
editor
and editing my own stuff and watching
the actors talking and i'm like yeah i
don't need any of this
is it it's gone
because i'm the editor it's
uh
yeah do you consider yourself an
industry guy
at the heart of it joe i guess to find
you said you didn't want to make the
industry your higher power but you did
for a while
oh yeah definitely and so
even though you're leaving to go
somewhere else
yep my assumption is you still plan on
being creative
oh that's not going to ever leave you
yeah i've
that's hardwired in me i've always been
making stuff
somehow forever always
from photography i started taking
pictures when i was like 11 or 12
and had a front page when i was 15 and
that was it i was going to be a
photographer because i had the top flap
of the front page of the kitchen journal
and i beat other photographers out on
that thing so
that made me feel like that um
i'm sorry i asked the question again
well are you do you consider yourself an
industry guy
in terms of keeping your finger on the
pulse of the industry
i've actually been ignoring the industry
for years while i've been here
uh i really don't uh i don't pay any
attention to box office i don't pay any
attention to what's new i don't pay
attention to
any of it i could be in des moines iowa
and do the same thing that i'm doing now
i just need actors
uh i'm sure there's actors in des moines
right
um yeah because the ir io
sorry writer's group yeah exactly um
so yeah i will always make
stuff i can't not make stuff
whatever stuff that is uh
uh living in albany will be different uh
because there's not a lot of people like
me
[Music]
and so i'm you're not gonna have
i'm never gonna hear the word call back
in a conversation in albany
i'm never gonna hear any kind of
industry
anything it's just and and it's going to
be weird because
i oh it would be weird it'll i'll be a
weirdo
because i will be surrounded by people
who don't
make stuff and my wife's an artist so
she makes stuff but yeah
it'll be a bit of a culture shock
plus the snow so well that'll be worse
but uh yeah i
i think the one thing by ignoring the
industry for
years um i
have sort of
preconceived in a way or or pre-planned
in a way how it's going to work when i'm
i'm not here in los angeles because all
the money that comes from crowdfunding
is does not come from los
angeles the people who support what i do
are not in los angeles
they're all over the world and
we just meet on the internet so
it doesn't matter where i am because
we meet on the internet that's my
neighborhood so
that's where i meet my neighbors that's
where i show my neighbors
the work i make so that is
so to them i won't move
to most people i'll be like oh you just
have a different background
for the cat pictures but otherwise
be exactly the same you know and i
haven't put out
i haven't put a short out in three years
four years now
so uh i have to go to get back and oh
yeah oh no i did collecting all right
maybe i did that
right i can't remember when i did clyde
spawning but regardless i haven't
i definitely haven't put anything out in
three years how do you think mike will
adjust to the weather
he's gonna hate it is he an indoor cat
okay
oh good big time big time yeah yeah but
he's
so i mean he hates the cult here
he's like gets under the covers when
it's winter here so he's gonna lose his
mind there
i'm sure his fur will get really thick
but that cat has been by my side
through uh the first short i made
my first i'm just gonna make
short
technically my second one um he was
next me when i wrote it he was next to
me when i cut it and he's been next to
me
for all the stuff that i've written
and edited he likes to hang out is he a
rescue
uh it wasn't like any burning buildings
or anything involved
uh we adopted them ferment or erect a
rescue
i know we adopted them from our vet had
a wing of cats
that were up for adoption oh okay and so
we
uh adopted them there i consider that a
rescue
that's nice it's a nice fit yeah it was
really great it was a really cool setup
because uh
we had a camper 18 years named dave and
when dave died we i was like
just like like more than a human died oh
yeah
and uh so i i i
like there's like how much time do i
want to give
you know what's the proper morning time
for
to lose a cat and then get another one
what's the amount of time
uh three months that's it i'm like i
gotta get another cat
and i'd never raised a cat from a kitten
ever
because dave was kathy's cat he was an
adult when we met
and her previous boyfriend didn't like
cats and she had two cats
and i grew up with cats so those cats
were like my wingmen
like they were like we got along great
oh yeah
yeah good uh good crew
joe what are you most excited about in
terms of when you leave los angeles
going to your new destination and
starting working on something
i guess
i'm i'm interested to see what happens
uh
with a production i've never i've never
like
put a crew together and and actors
any place but here so i'm kind of
looking forward to seeing what that
looks like
um and
you know when you rent locations out
here
or borrow locations or steel locations
or
whatever everyone kind of knows
that oh you're oh you're you we should
charge you because you're making a lot
of money on this right you're making
money right you got to be making money
and i don't think anybody in albany new
york is going to be you know
convinced that there's some giant
money-making machine
behind something so um
[Music]
it'll be uh i guess
i'm kind of looking forward to being the
weirdo i guess
in the room